hey guys I'm Jeff McDonald and instead
of your usual top five show III may be
over but I'm delivering your five
favorite picks for the best
announcements of the entire show so
let's get into it as for the games you
guys were pretty saw struck by no man's
sky evolved The Witcher 3
rise of the Tomb Raider the division and
so many more of the killer unannounced
and pre-announced titles be to be in the
press conferences let's get into the
best news items the first thing we
really need to mention if only for the
GF news nostalgia that we've been
talking about it so damn long is that
you don't have to wait much longer for
GTA 5 on PC and new gen consoles
developer Rockstar Games have also
promised graphical and technical boosts
including increased draw distances finer
texture details sent to traffic and
enhanced resolution the game will also
be getting new wildlife fancy weather
effects as well as damage effects all
current GTA 5 players are going to be
able to move their GTA online characters
and progression to the new platform when
the game's released across them later
this fall Sony entered their conference
not with the Last Guardian but with an
uncharted 4 so it was not bad we found
out that the game is entitled uncharted
for a feast and and we were treated to a
sweet-looking crazy high graphical
fidelity trailer it seemed to hint at
the game perhaps being the last in the
Uncharted saga but it could well just be
a dramatization since Naughty Dog of
promising drake's biggest adventure yet
blasphemous Deb's Neil druckmann and
Bruce Stanley are both on board so there
should be a lot to look forward to here
in addition to that we got to see
Rainbow six siege a reboot of Rainbow
six Tetris which is coming to Xbox one
ps4 and PC Ubisoft to prep the title to
be a counter-strike s5v five shooter
it'll consist of an all-out squad battle
where you attempt to do the surviving
and make the other team do the vast
majority of the dying the game includes
close-quarter angel battles and while
one squad and buddy
the other fight for the side of good as
rock guitarists the lesser can school
extra points by saving hostages earned
the matches play out over the space of
six poked round our second-to-last
killer reveal came from Dark Souls dev
from software who showed off their
upcoming action role-playing game
blood-borne the ps4 exclusive is being
touted for its dot and Tara filled
cosmic world and it really does look
insanely cool the game is set in an
ancient forgotten city known for an old
medical remedy which sufferers of all
sorts of ailments peek out although
naturally this vide itself is also super
cast and said curse comes in the form of
a horrible endemic illness so you know
irony think horrific be seized for the
killing and a game world that may even
be enough to legitimately give me the
creeps
it is totally won to keep an eye on and
a sprout top story and in my book my
favorite announcement of a training
hundr have officially said that a newer
so well 3d Zelda game is coming to the
Wii U we've been promised a huge
sprawling Hyrule lovely graphics as
displayed in the short trailer featuring
actual gameplay and a brand new truly
open world this game is not going to
feature the typical fairly rigid
progression of other Zelda titles
instead Nintendo are pretty happy to let
you go truly nuts wherever and whenever
like that would be for the first time
since classic Zelda where it was only
your own abilities and strength or black
bear of which kept you from moving
forward at any point in time those are
the 5 picks that I've got few but be
sure to let me know what your favorite
moments of the show have been it's been
awesome bringing you all the news as it
happens from e3 and we're super happy to
announce we have snagged ourselves a
Telly Award for Best online news program
so thanks very much to that we'll be
back on Wednesday with a whole stack
warn you so we shouldn't touch